bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors avant de parler de
l'épineux dossier un des essais
nucléaires à mon peut-être d'abord sur
la vaccination anti kovy dont 10 de
l'outre-mer quel est le parent pauvre de
cette vaccination est ce dû au manque de
doses en ce que le gouvernement réfute
ou à la défiance des habitants face aux
sérums alors ça tombe bien bonjour hans
à combien revient de l'arctique
je crois que là il ya une vraie volonté
de la pop en partie de la population ne
pas se faire vacciner alors résigné à un
défaut de renseignement
mais c'est vrai qu'ils étaient
confrontés avec mon match je me suis
retrouvé plusieurs fois dans une
situation où nous étions les seuls ceux
qui revenaient de métropoles de france a
porté le match après avoir échangé avec
les communes les nombres de ma famille
il y avait une très très grande méfiance
de la population par rapport à ceux de
vaccination alors clairement c'est sur
le dossier des essais nucléaires quel
manuel macron est attendue il y a déjà
eu une table ronde sur le sujet c'était
au début du mois quels sont les
engagements pris quels sont les
promesses qui ont été faites
monsieur d'alain à on a un peu oui vous
m'avez entendue jeudi
d'accord je disais donc il ya eu un déjà
une table ronde sur le dossier des
essais nucléaires en polynésie une table
ronde en début de ce mois
quels sont les engagements qui ont été
pris les promesses qui ont été faites
alors il est un fait
après trente ans il y des cellulaires
lui à 30 ans ont causé un maximum de
dégâts dans la population polynésienne à
savoir un corps exponentielle de cancers
de la thyroïde et que les choses ont
l'air de se répercuter génération après
génération jeu je ferai peut-être le
parallèle avec son âne ou en outre mais
inquiet leur cloisonnement par le chlore
ni les états volent la thématique enfin
moi j'avais été interrogé sur le fait
que la france devait demander pardon mes
qualités telles quelles actions le
président d'avec lui devrait devait
mener ici en polynésie pour réconcilier
l'ensemble de la france
c'est bien les français de l'hexagone et
les français de la communauté demander
pardon
puisque c'était là la thématique il me
semble que la france n'ait ne demandera
pas pardon
peut-être qu'elle fera des actions or à
la marge pour une prise n'est en prise à
des personnes atteintes par leur part
les différents cancers mais le mans dû
attendre le pardon de la france de
manière distincte
ce serait vraiment ça serait vraiment
exceptionnel il ne faut pas endigué
madame que mais les autres mais a plus
que je suis le président des français
il ne faut pas oublier que la france
soit bon ah c'est une première en
polynésie
elle a su parfaire son public en dans la
caraïbe est là aussi
elle maintient sa présence mais tout ça
dans une espèce de condescendance de
l'étape
les gens les questions nous sommes
demandeurs nous sommes des demandeurs et
finalement c'est la france qui doit donc
je ne m'attends pas justement donc vous
disiez que vous me donniez en tout cas
que peut-être l'état français avait
l'impression que les polynésiens étaient
des quémandeurs c'est exactement ce que
disait l'un des membres de l'association
193 dans ce sens ainsi la france ne
demandera pas pardon ne présentera pas
ses excuses qu'elle peut être la
réaction des polynésiens puisque c'est
ça qu'ils attendent aujourd'hui
alors ma foi je ne vis pas inconnu ici
j'y serai les études ma part de parler
de nos réactions
tout ce que je sais si peu au delà des
réactions
il faudra juger la france elle a son
explication à régler ce problème aussi
c'est un vrai problème de santé publique
qu'est ce que la france mise en place
pour réguler l homo ratel dédommager ces
populations qui sont qui ont été ont été
pollués comment fait comment fera t-elle
pour dédommager ans pour explorer un
terrain de sanitaires les atolls qui
sont pauvres ils sont pour son radio
activité
c'est là dessus qu'il faudra étudier la
france après qu'elle demande pardon ça
me semble aux anneaux sont anémiques
c'est surtout les actions que la france
fera les actions pour le président la
république annonce qui fera que la
france lui qui a commis elle aurait pour
nous définitivement la problématique de
santé un premier faux pas sa peur à ce
terrible bilan avec une demande pardon
ça souvent je suis prêt à parier que ça
ne
c'est simplement sur les actions qu'elle
mettra en place d'un budget france nous
sommes peut-être aussi en période de pré
commander veille près élection
présidentielle peut-être peut-être avec
le maquereau on ne sait jamais peut-être
sera-t-il il annonce qu'il fera que la
population se sentir consignes
daniel dalin merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du rrq réforme le conseil
représentatif des français d'autres
maire martial